今天想跟大家聊一個，我覺得很多中小企業主，甚至是我們這些上班族，聽了可能會覺得「怎麼可能」的案例。
怎麼說？是什麼事情聽了這麼出乎意料？
根據「Singularity Hub」的報導，現在有人真的能不用程式碼、不用大量員工，光靠 AI 工具，就打造出千萬甚至上億美元的事業。
等等，這裡我有疑問。你說不用程式碼、不用員工？這聽起來很像空頭支票，現在哪個創業不是要團隊、要技術？
這就是它讓我感到詫異的地方。一般我們想到創業成功，腦中浮現的往往是技術門檻很高、需要燒錢聘請工程師或大量人力。但這篇文章提到，有些成功的創業者，他們不是投入更多 AI 工具，而是找到一兩個能創造最大財務槓桿的關鍵點來應用 AI。
嗯，這點倒是有意思。如果不是「量」的問題，而是「點」的問題，那具體是怎麼做到的？總要有個例子吧。
文章裡提到一個「沒有工程師卻建立 4 億美元公司」的案例。這家公司提供一種「用白話描述應用程式」的服務，讓不懂程式的人也能打造出 App。
喔，所以它解決的痛點是「我不會寫程式」？把這個門檻直接移除了？
對，原文說這正是關鍵。他們找到了一個阻礙 99% 人進入某個行業的障礙——就是「我不會寫程式」——然後把這個障礙本身變成了一個產品。這就是所謂的「屏障消除者」模式。
這個概念聽起來很聰明。不過，這種模式能撐多久？當大家都發現了這個痛點，競爭者也會很快進來模仿吧？
其實原文也討論到一個很有趣的反轉案例。有一家公司曾經部署一個 AI 聊天機器人，取代了 700 名客服人員的工作，帶來了 4000 萬美元的利潤提升。
聽起來很成功啊，這為什麼會是「反轉」？
因為他們後來又把這些人類員工重新聘回來了。原文的重點是，很多人只看到那 4000 萬美元的利潤，卻沒去問：哪些對話是 AI 絕對不該碰的？
我懂了，是說在某些情境下，人與人之間的互動還是不可取代的。那麼，如果我是個中小企業主或主管，我可以從這個案例學到什麼？
我覺得最關鍵的，就是找出你行業裡那個「99% 的人做不到」的門檻是什麼，然後想辦法用 AI 把它移除掉，甚至把它變成你的產品。
換句話說，不是盲目地追求 AI 工具的數量，而是要思考 AI 能幫你解決哪個最核心、最有價值、最有「槓桿效應」的問題。比如，如果我開餐廳，AI 能不能幫我預測熱門菜色、或是更有效率地管理食材？
對，就是這個意思。它不是讓你把所有瑣碎的事都丟給 AI，而是把 AI 放在能創造最大效益的那個點上。
那一般上班族呢？這個概念對我們的工作或生活有什麼啟發？
我猜啦，這讓我們重新思考我們工作中的「門檻」是什麼。比如，是不是有什麼重複性很高、很多人覺得很麻煩，但其實可以用一些 AI 工具來加速處理的環節？
嗯，比如一些數據整理、報告撰寫的初步草稿，如果能用 AI 輔助，或許就能把更多精力放在策略思考或人際溝通上。這樣看來，AI 不再只是科技巨頭的專利，好像也提醒了我們，只要找到對的點，小人物也能有大槓桿。